[Musica]
quando raccontato alla mia famiglia ai
miei amici che fresata qui su questo
palco si è diffuso un certo stupore
perché io timida sono sempre stata
terribilmente timida per un certo punto
mi sono appassionata di ricerca
universitaria
ne ho fatto il mio lavoro oddio fatto si
sfida al precariato però ci proviamo e
nella ricerca universitaria parlare in
pubblico e ogni esigenza imprescindibile
poi mi piacciono anche le sfide quindi
perché limitarsi a parlare in pubblico
ho scelto come tema di ricerca in tema è
oggetto di tabù di stereotipi di stigma
sociale
il tema vero starete chiedendo
e quello dell'infertilità
già la parola evoca qualcosa
che è ricco di ostacoli e difficoltà
infertilità
ecco io oggi non vi parlerò di quanto è
struggente desiderare un figlio e non
riuscire ad averlo non lo farò perché
questa non è la mia storia potrebbe
essere un giorno ma per ora non lo è
e in questo contesto credo che la
propria azione sia uno strumento non
valido
quello che vorrei fare con voi oggi e
provare a ripensare come noi tutte noi
tutti ci rapportiamo all'infertilità
ecco per farlo faccio un passo indietro
fisico e metaforico e chiedo tutte l'ex
bambino e come me di ricordarsi che cosa
ci hanno ripetuto quando eravamo piccole
di dire di ricordarvi insomma di
riportare alla mente il fatto che ci
hanno raccontato una storiella che o
meno sempre uguale un bel giorno avremmo
incontrato l'amore il principe azzurro
che potesse essere una donna questo non
ci hanno mai detto
al grande amore sarebbe seguito al
matrimonio sontuoso rigoroso abito
bianco
infine di sicuro avremmo voluto dei
cigli e altrettanto sicuramente
sarebbero arrivati
ecco questa narrazione ha diversi
problemi
il primo è che madre non è una
definizione di donna madre non è nemmeno
sinonimo di donna madre una delle scelte
che una donna non è obbligata questo mi
fa sempre piacere ricordarlo perché
ancora oggi nel 2022
quando decidiamo per scelta di non avere
figli ci troviamo giustificarci perché
alla società in cui viviamo sembra
sbagliato che noi manchiamo di istinto
materno
il secondo problema della narrazione e
che la vita non è un film o quantomeno
non è un film dal finale spoilerato non
sempre possiamo sapere come andrà a
finire
specialmente quando si tratta di cercare
di avere un figlio
ecco perché quando si tratta di avere un
figlio può capitare che le cose vadano
un po diversamente da come abbiamo
creduto
l'infertilità un po come un percorso di
sopravvivenza in un parco tematico delle
attrazioni fatali
non so se vuoi ricordiate jurassic park
chiedo scusa a tutti gli appassionati
come me per questa sintesi estremamente
veloce che farò jurassic park film degli
anni 90 e un parco dove hanno ricreato i
dinosauri le aspettative di visitatori
sono altissime tutto andrà benissimo
sarà estremamente emozionante però va un
modo un pochino diverso in usare noi
dinosauri non si riescano a controllare
quindi questa visita diventa molto
pericolosa e con la fertilità e
l'infertilità sono un viaggio attraverso
un parco tematico le attrazioni però
sono fatali
perché l'infertilità non sempre si
presenta con dei sintomi evidenti non si
palesa non abbiamo una scritta sulla
fronte che ci avverte che potremmo avere
dei problemi
molto spesso l'infertilità è l'elemento
sorpresa che non vorremmo e quello che
non ci aspettavamo e che non sappiamo
come gestire
e questo elemento a sorpresa che è molto
spaventoso perché se desideriamo un
figlio facciamo ad averlo diventa
veramente inquietante non rimane da solo
ci sono altre bestiole molto feroci che
ci accompagnano in questo viaggio
io li chiamo le domande con la d
maiuscola ma possiamo anche chiamarle le
domande raptor le domande raptor c
accerchiano ci fissano e si nutrono nel
nostro disagio
ora per fare qualche esempio sono quelle
domande che penso che molti di noi
attorno i 30 anni abbiamo ricevuto ma
quindi quando lo fai un figlio lo sai
vero che si aspetti troppo poi diventa
troppo tardi
ma il figlio non arrivano lo state
cercando
ecco queste io le chiamo domande raptor
perché sono capace di squarciare in due
psicologi camente una persona che sta
facendo fatica ad avere un figlio
le domande raptor allora caratteristica
comune di essere poste con una certa
leggerezza chi depone magari non è
superficiale non si sta soltanto
domandando chi ha davanti
e davanti potrebbe avere una donna che
da mesi ed anni fa delle cure molto
pesanti ormonali dal punto di vista
psicologico economico fisico potrebbe
avere di fronte una donna che ha perso
un bambino ho avuto più aborti spontanei
ho avuto esperienza del lutto perinatale
potrebbe avere di fronte una donna che
ha avuto esperienza il tumore e le cure
per curarsi dal cancro le hanno tolto in
parto in tutto la possibilità di
diventare madre potrebbe avere anche
davanti una donna che non è nata con un
sistema riproduttivo standard da manuale
e non per questo è meno donna e non per
questo è meno capace di amore materno
ecco se vi parlo di donne non è certo
perché io credo che la fertilità ed
infertilità siano tematiche solo da
donne perché l'infertilità fa soffrire
anche gli uomini
perché anche gli uomini possono essere
infertili la grande differenza però è
che a livello culturale le domande
raptor accerchiano le donne le domande
con la d maiuscola è più difficile che
vendono posta un uomo quello che è certo
è che però anche gli uomini soffrono
l'infertilità e la stessa cultura carica
di stereotipi di genere che porta queste
domande verso le donne e la stessa
cultura che poi fa sì che un uomo si
senta meno virile meno uomo o meno
maschio perché non riesce ad avere un
figlio sono stereotipi di genere e
feriscono entrambe le parti in gioco
ecco per darvi per un'idea più nel
concreto parliamo un attimo di numeri
in europa 25 milioni di persone soffrono
di infertilità in italia una coppia su
cinque fa fatica a concepire i numeri
come potete intuire sono già grandi
e questo ci porta a pensare a un altro
stereotipo si pensa sempre che
l'infertilità riguardi una nicchia di
persone poche e di solito non siamo mai
noi compresi in questo in questo gruppo
e con non è così anche perché in questi
numeri in questi 25 milioni non sono
comprese tutte le persone che magari non
hanno le risorse economiche per
permettersi in una cura che magari non
hanno una rete sociale di supporto
perché il percorso per coralli
infertilità non è un percorso semplice a
livello psicologico perché magari non
hanno la forza psichica individuale non
c'è niente di male e quindi questi
numeri sono numeri già di loro molto
alti ma non ci dicono tutto ora abbiamo
parlato di europa
in europa ci sono 25 milioni di persone
che soffrono di infertilità c'è un altro
dato
l'infertilità una cura la cura più
diffusa la fecondazione assistita il
caso in cui un medico diciamo in termini
molto semplici aiuta una coppia a
concepire la fecondazione assistita è
chiaramente un argomento scientifico le
leggi sulla fecondazione assistita sono
diverse da paese a paese alcune leggi
sono più permissive altre sono più
proibitive questo porta a far sì che
alcune persone debbano viaggiare da un
paese all'altro per ottenere delle pure
questo tipo di fenomeno l'abbiamo
chiamato per anni turismo riproduttivo e
turismo credo che in tutti voi evochi
qualcosa di edonistico un piacere però
viaggiare per cercare di avere un figlio
non è sempre un piacere che più
un'esigenza sociale forte che c'è e di
cui il diritto spesso non tiene conto
infatti da giudizio dovrei dirgli che
quando una coppia cambia paese per
cercare un trattamento in realtà sta
illudendo in divieto è un delusione di
una norma la realtà è che un forte
bisogno sociale e l'altra realtà è che
il modo in cui noi parliamo le parole
che scegliamo danno la forma il modo in
cui pensiamo
quindi parlare di turismo riproduttivo e
fortemente sbagliato perché non c'è
niente di piacevole si chiamano cure
transfrontaliere
e ci descrivono molto meglio il fenomeno
ora a proposito tra l'altro altri casi
in cui scegliamo termini che sono
fortemente sbagliati c'è un'altra
opzione diciamo nel gioco in questo
gioco inteso chiaramente nella
sopravvivenza in questo parco tematico
può capitare che quando si cerchi un
figlio le cellule riproduttive i gameti
gli spermatozoi e ovociti
della coppia che è interessata non
riescano a portare al concepimento cosa
succede in questi casi c'è bisogno o di
un donatore e spermatozoi o di una
donatrice gli ovociti o magari di
entrambi
questa pratica nel nostro paese viene
chiamata a fecondazione eterologa
ora se voi prendesse vocabolari che di
sicuro vi hanno introdotto nelle bag di
oggi vedreste che il termine eterologo
si riferisce a quel caso in cui si usa
una cellula che viene trasportata da un
corpo all'altro ma i due corpi
appartengono specie diverse ecco quando
usiamo il concetto di eterologo
fecondazione eterologa noi portiamo a
pensare che chi nasce da questa cura se
a qualcuno di alieno estraneo
appartenente un'altra specie è per
questo che a livello di ricerca mi
impegno e cerco di utilizzare sempre il
termine di dono di gameti perché quello
che c'è alla base di questa pratica è un
dono non certo un
lo strano mix tra diverse specie e
questo ci porta a parlare di un altro
stereotipo
l'idea che il dna ci definisca
completamente come individui ma questo
non è vero il dna dice molto delle
nostre funzioni ma di noi come persone
dna che cosa dice
ecco da questo punto di vista quando si
parla di fecondazione assistita condono
di gameti lo stereotipo è quello per cui
i figli si ritengono veri solo quando
sono legati geneticamente i genitori e
quindi nella fecondazione assistita
condono di gameti lo stereotipo che in
realtà i figli non siano davvero di
quella coppia perché c'è stato
l'intervento di un donatore di una
donatrice
però il dna il dna non è un genitore
il rapporto tra un genitore figlio non
si definisce in termini di genetica ma
in termini di cura di affetto di amore
da questo punto di vista
quello che noi attivamente possiamo fare
sono almeno tre cose
come persone possiamo scegliere di non
esser i velociraptor come persone
possiamo scegliere di trattenerci dal
fare quelle domande che magari facciamo
con pura curiosità giusto nell'interesse
per sapere se l'altra persona vuole un
figlio ecco quelle domande tratteniamo
c.hall farle per un semplice motivo
perché abbiamo la consapevolezza che
potrebbe esserci qualcosa dall'altra
parte che porterebbe la persona a
soffrire enormemente
la fertilità a decine di varianti e
centinaia di migliaia di volti per
rispettare le storie di queste persone
non è necessario conoscerle tutte ci
basta sapere che esistono poi per noi
ricercatrici studiose che cos'è che
possiamo fare da un lato possiamo
lavorare per creare dei modelli
giuridici delle leggi che quando
regolano un argomento scientifico come
la fecondazione assistita dialoghino con
la scienza e non certo con le ideologie
perché le ideologie non sono né bra
ricercatori ne bravi medici e perché
quando scegliamo delle che si fondano
sulle ideologie di solito non abbiamo
delle leggi inclusive ma delle leggi
implicitamente giudicanti e questo corto
circuito tra scienza diritto è molto
pericoloso nella vita di tutti i giorni
non solo nella pura teoria la seconda
cosa che possiamo fare come ricercatrici
e una sana rigorosa e appassionata
divulgazione portare in termini semplici
alle persone questi concetti complessi
per creare consapevolezza un sapere che
si è diffuso perché soltanto in questo
modo con un sapere diffuso possiamo
uscire tutti insieme da questo parco
tematico
lasciando indietro stereotipi tabù e
stigma sociale con la loro ingiusta
ferocia
grazie
[Applauso]